Okay welcome back to Gary's Economics
thank you for waiting today
we're gonna get you up to speed
with everything you missed
and talk about
how we are gonna fix this economic collapse
in the rest of 2025 welcome back
okay so first thing to cover is
I think to pat ourselves on the back a little bit
I've been away three months and
I was a little bit worried about taking time off
when things are blowing up
but I needn't have been because
things have gone absolutely mental
with wealth taxes and with inequality
since I've been away. Normally when I'm working
I sit here at my kitchen table and I've got a TV there
and I run BBC News or Sky News
and then I have it on mute
and every single time they talk about the economy
there's a little thing at the bottom saying
wealth taxes, are we gonna get wealth taxes?
Every single time
a politician is asked to talk about the economy,
the political situation, they are asked
are you gonna do wealth taxes?
Why are you not doing wealth taxes?
Why are you not taxing the rich more?
While I was away
we had the Guardian come up with an editorial piece
saying we need to have wealth taxes.
Just this weekend we had Lord Kinnock
former leader of the Labour Party
asking why we're not doing wealth taxes,
and yesterday we had a, well
I'm shooting this on Wednesday,
yesterday we had a Yougov poll coming out
saying that 75% of the country
including 62% of conservative voters
support wealth taxes.
I don't wanna get too egotistical about it but
this is because of us.
This is because of us, this is because of me
this is because of you amplifying our message,
it's not just us
we have to give like a big shout out to,
other people push this Tax Justice UK especially
the Patriotic Millionaires of Becca
Gowland at PMUK does great work
Aaron Advani people like that
but this is us.
We've driven this into the narrative,
we are a massive massive part of the conversation now,
politicians have to talk about it all the time.
So just a a little moment to say well done.
This channel,
the idea, the political idea of this channel
was always that we amplify through ordinary people
we we talk to ordinary people
in a way that is understandable for ordinary people
and you guys amplify the message
you know we never done any advertising
and it's you that grows us
so first things first, like well done
like we've massively
we've changed the game on this
you know, we are the new Rupert Murdoch,
we are we are dominating the debate
and we've done it through
videos of me sitting here in my kitchen.
But it's more because of you guys who watch it so
thank you very much
let's keep doing it. We're back now
hopefully for the rest of the year
so let's keep pushing this through.
So let's catch up a little bit with the broad economic
political situation
the reason that wealth taxes have become like
relevant is because the economy is shit,
and the economy is shit in exactly the way
which I said it would be shit
before the new government came in
and to be honest
this is relevant even if you're in the US
or or in other countries.
I would like to add the last three months
I've been like traveling the world
and I've been doing events
talking about politics and about economics
and the same things are happening everywhere
so what I'm about to say is,
it's not just relevant to the UK or the US
basically everywhere you have the same situation
which is there's kind of like two flavors of
of government that you have at the moment
which is either this kind of like boring centrist,
let's just be more efficient
let's just be more practical and sensible
and somehow that will fix things
and you have this like
kind of increasingly mentalist far right
which is just like going crazy
doing a lot of crazy shit
but aggressively blaming immigrants and foreigners
and you know
these two kind of
flavours of modern government are like
really typified by, at the moment
the Keir Starmer Labour government here in the UK
and the Donald Trump
Republican government over in the US.
And I came up before those guys came in and I said,
or it might have been just after,
basically said what you have here
is something really interesting
because you've got these two
kind of opposite flavours of government
which is your like very sort of sensible
practical traditional, centrist
Keir Starmer government and this kind of like wild
far right, alt right
whatever you want to call them
Donald Trump government
that are kind of set up as opposites
but they will both fail on the economy
because both of them are failing to recognise the key
fundamental economic problem that you have
which is that wealth inequality is growing very very
very very quickly
that the rich
and the super rich are growing their wealth
very aggressively
that is squeezing out and bankrupting governments
and that is squeezing out
and bankrupting the middle class
and because wealth taxes
and tax on the super rich are not really on the table
you end up with the situation
you have, governments who have collapsed their wealth,
given away all of their wealth,
are hugely in debt
turning to a middle class
who is also quite aggressively losing its wealth
and saying well
you need to pay more and absolutely refusing to
look at this group of people who
are just absolutely squeezing everybody else out
and it's gonna fail basically
you know this is like if you have
you know you've got a patient on the operating table
and they're hemorrhaging blood
the government is hemorrhaging wealth
the middle class is hemorrhaging wealth
and you you try to fix it
without stopping that hemorrhaging of wealth
you know the boat
the boat has a hole in the bottom
and you're not gonna fix it by rowing faster
and you're not gonna fix it by blaming immigrants
until we stop the middle class
the working class and the governments
from having all of their wealth
squeezed out of them by the very rich
we will continue to see economic worsening
and this is why I was able to predict that Rishi Sunak
would fail economically
that Keir Starmer would fail economically
that Donald Trump would fail economically,
despite these three guys, Sunak and Starmer and Trump
being very different politicians
and it's really just for a very simple reason
which is the core of the economic crisis
is growing wealth inequality
and none of these politicians
none of these political ideologies
are willing to even really talk about inequality
and in fact in many cases
especially the case of Donald Trump
and the more far right parties
they're actively cutting taxes on billionaires.
So you know
what you have here is an economy with cancer
and a bunch of politicians who don't believe in cancer.
So it doesn't matter if it's Starmer on the tin
or Trump on the tin,
they're gonna fail
they're gonna fail unless they deal with
economic inequality
which is a big problem
because they're not addressing it.
But it creates this massive
massive political opportunity
which is that what you will see
what we are seeing, what we will continue to see
is continued economic failures
of different governments
because they refuse to deal with the actual problem.
In many cases
I think they don't,
they don't recognise the importance of inequality
as the actual problem
and if you wanna understand specifically
why it is that governments
and politicians
and economists don't realize why economics is
why inequality is the problem
we do have a video on the channel called
Understanding Why Economists Ignore Inequality.
We'll put that in the in the description at the bottom
but basically these guys will fail again and again
and it puts us in a great position
because we can correctly predict that.
So I came in before Starmer came in
saying that he would win and he would
fail really badly on the economy
and he would be very unpopular.
I said the same thing about Sunak
I said the same thing about Trump
and it also creates this
massive demand for something new
because people don't want to live in poverty
people don't want their kids to live in poverty
but it's increasingly clear to ordinary people
that is what is happening
that they're being impoverished
and it creates this massive demand
for new economic ideas which I think we
here on this YouTube channel are filling, really
and I think that's one of the reasons why this channel
has become so so big and
and so popular
and when I was traveling around the world
I realised that it's
it's like popular all over the world really
which is kind of crazy
but that's because these
these problems are happening everywhere
so there's massive opportunity,
I'm back now we're gonna make videos
we're gonna try to drive into that space
I think there's such a massive gap
to explain to people what's happening
in the economy and that gap is only gonna grow
as the economy gets worse and worse
but that opportunity which is there for us
to explain why economic worsening is happening
is not just being exploited by us here on this channel
it's also being exploited by the far right and
I think it's interesting to consider
what will happen politically
and how these two different political ideologies
will respond to
continuing aggressive economic worsening
worsening of living standards
so when you consider these kind of like
centrist governments
and I think that includes
not just governments like Starmer and Labour
and Biden and the Democrats
but also for example
the Rishi Sunak Conservative government was
more or less a kind of boring centrist government
economically, when they fail on the economy
they are really quite fucked to be honest
because when your position is this kind of like
radical centrism and your offer is just
we're gonna be really sensible,
when you try to be really sensible
and the economy fails
you basically don't have anywhere to move.
These guys
continually find themselves in the same situation
which is they make promises,
they enter government, they realise
that the government's given all of its wealth away
they turn to the middle class
who have also not had their wealth protected
and then they just basically say
we're fucked
we're gonna just basically shut the welfare state down
and then that makes them very unpopular
these centrists have have not really got anywhere to go
and that is a problem because the new right
the far right whatever you wanna call them
they do have somewhere to go
which is it's really
really obvious what these guys are gonna do
when they fail on the economy
and Donald Trump will fail on the economy
if he's judged by broad living standards
because he's not dealing with the growing inequality
they they have people to blame right
they say we were stopped by the centrists
we were stopped by the academics
the Supreme Court, the media
these negative elements within our society
they didn't allow us to be aggressive enough on
immigration and foreigners
and then you,
you shift further to the right
and you have that space to move into
and you really see that here in this country
We had the Cameron/Osborne government
who were not aggressively far right
especially on social issues
they failed on on the economy
and they were replaced by Boris Johnson
who was further to the right
on these social issues and then he again
failed on the economy and he was replaced,
well it looks like he will be replaced by Nigel Farage
who is further to
the right on these social issues
and basically this will keep happening
you will see this flip flop
which is the centre fails on the economy
because they failed to deal with inequality
they're replaced by someone on the right
they fail because
they fail to deal with growing inequality
in the economy
and they're replaced either by someone in the centre
or somebody further right
because you you need
when you can see that the status quo is failing
you always need to be able to sell yourself politically
as something new and I think unless really
the centre or something on the left is able to come up
and actually deal with this rapidly growing inequality
which is crushing the middle class
and crushing governments
it is inevitable that we will see a progression
of further and further right governments
and I'm not saying that Farage or Trump are fascists
uh if you wanna say that
that's up to you
if we don't fix the economic problem
we will inevitably get further
and further and further to the right
governments that are more and more extreme
because
it's the only way that politicians can sell themselves
as new and sell themselves as believably
being able to fix the economic problem.
So at this point
I would like to send a message out to the Labour Party
look look
I don't hate you
I don't know what you guys feel about me
I don't want this country to go to shit
and I don't want this country to descend into like
extreme fascism
and I'm not saying that's what Farage is
but I know that that's where we will go
if we don't fix this economic problem
you guys won election one year ago
you've got four years until the next election
listen I don't know what you think about me
I've got a very long track record of good predicting
I get paid millions of pounds by banks
to tell them this stuff
I'm telling this to you for free
if you do not deal with this
rapidly growing inequality of wealth
the economy will collapse
and you guys will get absolutely smashed
at the next election but more importantly than that
this country will collapse into desperate
desperate poverty I don't want that to happen
and I'm hoping that you don't want that to happen
this week I've sent a few emails out to guys in Labour
I've tried to set up a few meetings
so we can go and speak to them
to see if they're interested in fixing this problem
I've got to be honest
I'm not super confident that the guys I've spoken to
are gonna be able or willing
to seriously think about fixing this problem.
iI there's anyone out there,
one MP in the Labour Party
who doesn't want the country to go to shit
then fucking send me an email alright
because at the end of the day
I'm a Youtuber
this channel is probably gonna get bigger and bigger
and bigger
coming up to the next election
I'm gonna try and make it so you fucking need us
but more importantly
I don't want the country to collapse
if there's one single MP out there in Labour
that doesn't want the country to collapse
get in touch because the truth of the matter is
if Labour doesn't deal with this
which it looks like they won't
the economy will get worse and worse
and worse and worse Labour will get more and more
and more and more unpopular
Starmer will get more and more unpopular
Reeves will get more and more unpopular
they will end up in a position
where they will probably be forced to do a massive
rebrand and probably change leadership
before the next election
and I want that
new leader, and it doesn't have to be a new leader
by the way, listen, Starmer
if you're out there
I'll be happy to work with you, you know
it's my country too you know
I don't want it to go to shit and and I hope you don't.
Whoever is in charge of the Labour Party
going to the next election
if we do not have an offer on the table
that is serious about reducing inequality
then it will be Farage
it will be Reform and I worry about what that means so
as this channel grows and grows
we become more and more politically powerful.
After this video
we'll be doing a lot more economics explainers
we're gonna do one on housing,
why housing is expensive next week
but we do have to sort of recognize what we are
I don't do this channel
just because I like talking about the economy
I do it cos I don't want the economy to collapse
and for whatever you or I might think
because of the political system
we have in this country I don't see any realistic way
of fixing the economy without going through Labour
and it doesn't mean I won't talk to the greens
or anyone else who,
or the Liberal Democrats
or even conservatives or Reform
but I think our best chance
is to try to get Labour to not be so aggressively shit
so I'm here if you want to talk to me.
OK so on that message
on a message to Labour
I wanna send out a few more messages to people
just here at the beginning of what I'm gonna call the
the summer autumn season
summer autumn 2025 season of Gary's Economics
the first thing to say is
you know I...
when I started this channel doing videos in my mate
Simran's garden
I never thought that it would really come to anything
and I didn't think we really had much chance of winning
but I thought it was important to do
and Simran always thought we had a good chance
I think we might win this
The speed of the growth is absolutely incredible
and you know
we've already had our big press campaigns with the book
last year and this year and
you know
maybe it's gonna struggle without those press campaigns
we've got some cool stuff,
some TV stuff like lined up for like this year,
or it might come out early next year
which I'm hoping will bring more
bring more attention
but I think we've got a massive chance.
I think it should be obvious
that social media is becoming
and is going to become more and more powerful in
in the realm of mainstream politics
and the traditional political parties
and also
a lot of the traditional media have been super
super slow to move on that
I heard that the other day
that Nigel Farage has more TikTok
followers than all of the rest of the other 649 MPs
put together.
Politics and media has been slow to adapt to the demand
for politics and economics on social media
and we're here, we're here
we must be one of the biggest politics
economics social media platforms in Europe
we're growing super quickly
we already dominate the debate
I think we can win, I think we can win
I think we've got a chance
so stick it out, stick in
keep following. I'm hoping to keep making videos
as good this season as they were last season
but I wanted to send a message to
all my international viewers
because in the last three months
I've been all over the world
I was in Japan
Korea
Italy, Portugal
Sweden and Norway
and I did events in almost all of those countries.
Everybody's got the same problems
I know we're mainly watched in the UK and the US
but the truth is we are getting closer and closer
to actually getting some kind of implementation
of a fairer tax system here in the UK
not just because of this channel
but because of the work of what we do here
and other great campaigners here in the UK
we are not the center of the world anymore
this is gonna be very very difficult to fix just here
just in the UK. It's gonna be much
much easier
if we have other countries willing to help us
protect ourselves from billionaires all over the world
so you know I'd like to reach out to
all of the people who watch in other countries
thank you very much for your support
please try and build up this message
in the countries that you're in
it's a very simple message,
the reason for falling living standards is growing
wealth inequality
government and the middle class are being squeezed out
that inequality is continuing to grow rapidly
if you don't do anything about it
then living standards
and the economy will continue to collapse.
You need to understand that in your country
as well as in my country,
if we build this message up
we can stop it. The last time
we significantly reduced inequality
in the western world it wasn't done just here in the UK
it was done across Europe
including the US and including places like Japan.
We did it together
and I think we can do it together again.
If you're interested in seeing some of my interviews
across the world
I think there's one of my interviews in Portugal
one of my interviews in Italy
and one of my interviews in Japan
including a section of me speaking Japanese are all up
I'll put them
I'll put them up in the comments.
I wanted to send a message out to
people that are voting
or considering voting for the far right parties
Reform, Donald Trump
whatever, Chega in Portugal
they're all over the place.
You know who they are, you've got one in your country
look you know
I know I get branded as a
as a communist and shit like that
I don't hate you
if you're trying to vote for these people
if you're considering voting for these people
like I know the message is going out there
that the reason you’re poor is immigrants
the reason you’re poor is foreigners
I know that message goes out again and again
and again and again
and I know that ordinary people are struggling
and they're worried about the future and
and their financial position
and the financial positions of their kids
and their grandkids, and I'm worried as well
I don't come from a rich background
I know what life is like for ordinary people
and I know it's a lot of ordinary
poor people that are voting for these guys
I don't hate you, I do this for you
I don't need to do this you know
I'm financially secure, and if you want low immigration
you have every right to ask for that
but before you consider voting for far right parties
I want you to always ask yourself two questions.
Who funds these guys?
And what are they gonna do to billionaire taxes?
because in almost every case
you will find that
these guys are funded by billionaires
and are trying to cut billionaire taxes
these billionaires are the guys who are gonna own
the houses that your kids need
they are the guys that are taking
the wealth that your government used to have
they are the guys that are bankrupting your countries
and your welfare state. Listen
I'm not here to talk about immigration
I'm not an immigration economist
I'm an inequality economist
and you can have whatever level of immigration
that you like seriously
but please
don't vote for billionaires who are gonna bankrupt you.
OK I wanted to send out two more short messages
I wanted to send one to the working class
that don't trust the middle class. Listen
I come from a working class background and you know
now I like move in some fancy circles sometimes
when I have to and
sometimes I don't trust them either
I know they can be kind of dickheads
and they can sometimes be quite annoying.
You're not gonna get out of this without their support
There's gonna be a lot of the media
trying to make you hate people
a bit richer than you, a bit posher than you
and I know that
you are the guys who are on the front line
and you are the guys who are getting hurt.
If the working class
and the middle class can't stand together
then the rich and the super rich will win
so stay cool yeah
don't worry I see you.
And to the middle class
that don't trust the working class, listen
you know
I know you guys might not be in the sharp end of it now
but once the rich have taken
all the wealth of the government
and all the wealth of the poor
whose wealth do you think they're gonna take next
you know
don't be stupid
don't be stupid.
OK finally,
just for I end
I wanted to send a message to the rich and
and the super rich because
you know
as this channel has grown and as my message has grown
and as this wealth tax stuff has grown
there has been inevitably a lot of pushback
and I know that a lot of that pushback
comes from rich and super rich people
or is ultimately funded by rich and super rich people
and I know why you do that
because you don't wanna pay higher taxes
I understand, I don't wanna pay higher taxes either
I don't like it
if you are rich or if you are super rich
you have a nice life right
you know I've seen how you guys live
and I know you know how you live right
it's nice you know
you guys get a lot of luxury, and it's cool
by pushing this further and further and further
and taking more and more and more
you are aggressively destabilising the economies
and political systems of the countries
which you live in and which give you extreme luxury,
what the fuck are you doing?
It's enough, it's enough
and you know
we have these stories in history
I don't know how true they are
that you know
when the British elites got so rich
they eventually decided to do things
like more philanthropy and
you know
help set up the welfare state and help protect the poor
and for that reason you know
they were able to protect
the political stability of the countries they lived in
whereas the French elites
they didn't give anything back
they did all their let them eat cake shit
and they get their heads chopped off
look I ain't trying to cut nobody's heads off
You've got enough, if you keep pushing
you will destabilise the countries
that give you these enormous amounts of wealth,
look at what happened in history
look at what happened in the 20th century
I'm not trying to redistribute wealth
away from the rich
I'm trying to stop the redistribution
that is bankrupting ordinary people.
Listen I'm out here with my white flag up
I would accept a peace treaty
let's stop it now. If you keep pushing under this system
where you don't pay tax and the poor pay tax
and you increasingly take everything
and bankrupt everybody else
you will destroy the political stability
of this country
so stop finding dickheads to argue me on the news.
OK that's it
that's the end of this week's video
not a lot of economics in this week's video
but um we're gonna
come back
with the same kind of stuff that we've always done
Next week
I wanna do a video on why housing is so expensive
which I think is one we haven't covered for ages
it's really really important
my plan this year is to run through
till the end of the year
I've got like some TV shit I'm working on as well
it's keeping me busy
but if my mental health holds up
and I don't get assassinated by the Financial Times
We will be back
running these videos till the end of the year
Shit’s gonna be hard, stay cool
be there for each other
what I would like you to do is just
stick to the message one simple clear economic message
the reason for growing poverty
the reason for falling living standards
is growing wealth inequality
that is worsening rapidly
if we don't deal with it things get worse
we can deal with it, it's possible, tax the rich more
Tax wealth not work
Welcome back hope you're enjoying summer, thank you